hello everyone welcome back to cs224n
and today i'm delighted to introduce our
final guest speaker
euless vetkov so yulia is currently a
professor at carnegie mellon university
but actually starting from next year
she's going to be a professor at the
university of washington as you can
already see updated in her email address
julia's research focuses on extending
the capabilities of human language
technology beyond individual cultures
and across language boundaries so lots
of work that considers the roles of
human beings and different multilingual
situations and today she's going to be
giving a talk to us on social and
ethical considerations and nlp
systems just one more note on the
way things are going to run um so you
only have some interactive exercises so
what we're going to do is for the
interactive exercises you'll be asked to
put something into the zoom comments so
that i'll sorry the zoom chats that
means really using the chat and you
might want to set who the two to the
chat is to i think it's by default
panelists which is okay or to yulia so
it goes to her panelists is good but
probably not all attendees because
they'll be a bit overwhelming and then
if you have questions um put them in the
q a
as usual because they'll keep the two um
streams separate and as for our other
invited um
lectures if you've got some questions
that you'd like to ask julia at the end
stay on the line and raise your hand and
we can promote people to be um panelists
and have a chat with you leah okay so
without further ado i'm delighted to
have you julia
thank you very much chris i'm very
excited
to speak to you all today despite
unfortunately i cannot see you but i'm
excited
and uh
so this lecture is uh structured as
follows we'll have uh three parts the
first part will be primarily a
discussion in which i will ask questions
it's supposed to be interactive but i
realize
we we are very limited in ways we can
interact now so this is when please put
responses if you want in the chat window
and i will answer my own questions
following also your responses and maybe
read some of your responses so this will
be the first part and the goal of this
part is to provide you some practical
tools when you have a new problem to
work on in
ai in in your field
how would you assess this problem in
terms of how ethical it is to solve it
what kind of biases it may incorporate
and so on
so in the second part i will try to
generalize to
give a review of what are
overall topics in the intersection of
ethics in nlp because it's actually a
very big field and what i will talk
about today is just the
motivational lecture but there is a lot
of technical interesting technical
content and a lot of subfields of this
field
and i will dive a little deeper in one
topic in this field
specifically focusing on algorithmic
bias
and if time is left which i'm not sure
about i will talk about one or two
projects in my lab so specific research
projects but if we don't have time to
cover it then you can always read the
paper so the first first two parts are
more important for the purpose of this
lecture
so let's start
uh
this is as far as i understand this is
the course on deep learning and natural
language processing so you probably
covered various deep learning
architectures and their applications to
various nlp tasks like machine
translation dialogue systems question
answering
and there is an obvious question
what does it all has to do with ethics
what does syntactic parsing or part of
speech tagging has to do with ethics
and the answer
[Music]
which i want to suggest is uh this quote
that the
it's a simple answer that
the common misconception is that
language has to do with words but it
doesn't it has to do with people so
every word every sentence that we
produce language is produced by people
it is directed towards other people and
everything that is related to language
necessarily involves people and it has
social meaning and incorporates human
biases
and this is why also models that we
build
um
which will be used by other people may
incorporate social biases
so this is why decisions that we make
about our data
uh all kinds of considerations that we
incorporate
into our model may have direct people
direct impact on people and maybe
societies
and to start this lecture we need to
start with understanding
um
what is ethics so what is ethics here is
a definition from a textbook on ethics
ethics is a study of what a good and bad
ants to pursue in life
and what is right and wrong to do in the
conduct of life
so it is a practical discipline
and their primary goal is to determine
how
one ought to live and what what actions
one ought to do in the conduct of one's
life
so to summarize it is very practical
and it's simple it's just
doing the good things and doing the
right things
then my question to you is
how simple it is to divide to define
what is good and what is right
so let's start
discussion by diving into various
problems
and we start with a boring theoretical
problem which everybody knows about
which is a trolley dilemma and we'll we
won't spend too much time on it so just
i'm sure all of you know about it
so it's a classical problem in ethics in
which uh
so this is you standing near the lever
and here is a trolley coming and there
are several people so the trolley cannot
see the people and the people cannot see
the trolley and you are the only one
um
in control in charge
you can save people
and maybe you need to make decisions
about people's life and you ask yourself
why me
but uh
the point here is that
uh imagine that uh
there are five people on one side
and the no one on the other side and
then i would ask you would you pull the
lever to save five people if the trolley
is supposed to go straight
and uh
and
i if i would ask you interactively
everybody would say yes i will pull the
lever and then i will follow up with the
next question okay what about if five
people on one side and only one person
on the other side so would you pull the
lever to minimize
the number of
lives that will be sacrificed
and some people will not answer some
people will say yes
some people will say no and those who
will say yes i will ask them what if
this one person is your brother and on
the other side just five random people
what would be your answer and i can go
on and on and on to make this problem
harder and harder and
as you can imagine
there are
the answers are difficult
and also
we don't know what the answer will be in
the actual situation
and while this problem is theoretical it
is in part becoming relevant now when we
talk about self-driving cars
so i am now moving to
closer to the topics that we will
discuss today and i want to introduce a
new problem
which i call the chicken dilemma
so in this dilemma
let's train a classifier
and in
this will be a simple cnn classifier
and the the classifier the input to the
classifier is an egg
and
the classifier needs to define the
gender of the chicken of the chick
so and decides if it's a hen it will go
to lay egg laying farm
and if it's a rooster it will go to a
meat farm
so first of all do you think you can
build such a classifier
i'm sure every student in this course
will easily build this classifier and
i'm sure it will have quite a good
accuracy
and then the question to you is do you
think it is ethical
and i invite you to type your responses
in the chat
yes no i mean you can you can justify a
little bit
thank you thank you for participating
so could you repeat the question so the
question is uh there is an egg and you
need to determine the gender of the
chick and if it's a rooster it will go
to a meat farm and if it's a hen it will
go to an egg laying farm
and
the question is is this ethical
so there are all kinds of responses
let's see
so yes and no
but you can use
same thing to target
acne groups instead on chickens so yes
thank you and i see there are many
interesting responses here i just
the amount of responses i cannot even
have time to read them because
so anyway
so based on this question
i can tell you what my thoughts are
so as a vegetarian i
maybe think it's unethical but as a
mother
i actually want my kids to eat meat
and whether i think it's ethical or not
we are doing this anyway today
and there are all kinds of
considerations uh pros and cons
for example this is what already is done
today and then maybe such classifier
will minimize the suffering of the
animal
but on the other hand we hope that in
the future
society uh the life of a chicken will be
as valuable as the life of a person and
i can't continue on and on but from this
example i also don't want to stay on it
too long
you can see that the questions of ethics
are difficult
that
whether like you you don't know too much
about the
this field
but
you can feel what is the right answer so
ethics is inner guiding its moral
principles
and
there are often no easy answers so there
are many gray areas
and importantly ethics changes over time
with the values and beliefs of people so
whatever we discuss today we can think
it's ethical or not ethical
but
it may change in the hundreds of years
and maybe 100 years ago this would not
even be a question why this would be
unethical
and another important point is that
this is what we are doing today so what
is ethical is what is legal is not
necessarily aligned we can do legal
things that will still be unethical
and now having this primer i want to
move to the actual problems the actual
problems that we can
kind of be asked to build and decide
whether we want to build them or not
and the way i will guide this discussion
is i will ask you specific questions
will ask you for your answers and i
realize it's very difficult to read the
chat for specific answers but
the point is that the types of questions
that i will ask you
this would be the questions that you
could ask yourself
when you need to build a technology and
maybe the question whether something is
ethical or not is a difficult question
but let's try to break down
analysis of a specific application of a
specific model
to
kind of derive an answer which
which will give us some tools to derive
an answer in an easier way
so here is the next classifier uh
classifier that we want to build
we want to build an iq classifier so we
will be talking about predictive
technology
so
based on people's personal data for
example facial images and maybe we can
collect this the text of these people on
social media media
let's predict
the iq of the person
so
if you don't know what iq is
iq is
is a general capacity of an individual
to consciously adjust
the thinking to new requirements so it's
basically how intelligent a person is
so this is already not a hypothetical
problem you can collect individuals data
you can collect their texts online and
you collect and you can collect training
data to predict people's iq
but when i will ask you is this an
ethical question or not it might be a
difficult
question to answer immediately
thank you very much for participating i
really appreciate i hope i can save this
chat later
and to read the answers
okay so let's start with the first
question
uh we need to
predict people's iq from their photos
and text
and then the first question that if i
ask you is it ethical or not
i don't know and then you can ask
yourself first
who would benefit from such technology
so can you think who would benefit from
a technology that predicts an iq of a
person
hiring
right employers
schools universities so you see answers
right so overall it can be a useful
technology right
immigration services can benefit from it
right and invite only
smart people to immigrate to a country
right
it
even individuals with high iq can
benefit from this right because uh they
would maybe not need to do gre and sat
will they will not need to write essays
they will just need to show the iq
okay so this technology can potentially
be useful
and then
the the next question is
let's assume we can build such a
technology i will show you later that we
actually cannot but even if we can build
such a technology
let's think about corner cases and
understand who can be
harmed by this technology so basically
what is the potential for dual use
how this technology can be misused
so
assume that the classifier is 100
accurate now for a second and please
think about it and type
what do you think who can be harmed from
such a classifier and how this
classifier can be misused
right so
i can see answers
and
i wish we can have this interactive but
i can try to summarize what i have read
so far
so
first of all one of you wrote that
iq
is
let me just answer my question because
it's difficult to summarize the chat
yeah the interact the interactive
feature is difficult
so
[Music]
so i would i would think about it in
this way
first of all
why would we want to build such a
classifier
so to build the classifier to predict an
iq
uh companies universities they don't
really need to know your queue
what they are trying to predict is
your future success
the way you will succeed in a job or the
way you will study at school
and then
the question is is iq is the right proxy
for future
success and the answer is
no iq correlates with future success
but it's not necessarily the right proxy
for future success
and then who are people who could be
harmed
for example people who have lower iq but
very hard working people
people who have lower q but have good
soft skills
so
uh
assuming that
so first of all the
iq as a proxy of future success is a
incorrect bias proxy
and this kind of problem of using a
proxy to the actual label because we
cannot have the actual label the future
success we cannot have this label it's
actually very very common in other types
of predicting technology if you think
about parole decisions
technology that uses that decides on
parole decisions what they want to
predict is whether the individual
recommit the crime
but this is a label that is very hard to
obtain
and this is why they might resort to
another label
whether they whether this individual
will be
convicted of a crime again
and build this technology to predict
future conviction but conviction of a
crime is a biased proxy of the actual
objective that we want to have the
likelihood to to make the crime
and this is one example of a bias proxy
which does not allow us us to build the
right application
for the goals that we have so this is
one problem
the second problem is iq test itself
it is a bias test so actually we cannot
build a pro
[Music]
an accurate classifier for
future for
the right iq
and also if we look at the data that we
use
this data
picture photos or social media
this data is biased itself so there are
all kinds of biases because of which we
cannot actually build the right model
this is why this classifier will not be
100 accurate but there will be many
individuals who can be harmed
and then there will be questions for
example
um
assume our our classif the classifier
that we build
is not actually accurate but it's
has high accuracy for example
90 or 95
and then i would ask you is 95
a good accuracy
or 99 a good accuracy
and then
there are questions to think about
is whether um what would happen with
misclassification
what would what would be an impact on
individual lives if the classifiers
makes mistakes and in this case the
important point is that
the cost of misclassification is very
high it has effect on people's life so
accuracy maybe not the right evaluation
measure for this classifier
and another question that i could ask
is
for example this condition on the slide
that we find out that white females have
99 accuracy
but people with blonde hair under age 25
have only 6 60 accuracy so what does it
tell you about this classifier
right
so the the data set itself is biased
this means
this means basically that people with
blonde hair under the age of 25 are
underrepresented in your data set
so there are all kinds of questions and
all kinds of probing questions that you
can ask about the classifier to
understand is this the right problem to
solve
who can be harmed
am i optimizing towards the right
objective is my data biased and what is
the cost of misclassification
how do i assess the potential for the
use and how much harm this technology
can bring in addition to how much how
useful it can be
and then one last question which is a
hard one
i want to ask you who is responsible
so i'm your manager in google and you're
working and i come to you and i ask you
please build the iq classifier
and you build an iq classifier and you
publish a paper about the iq classifier
and
this paper is publicized on media
so and then the question is who is
responsible is it the researcher or
developer is it the manager
is it the reviewer who didn't catch the
problems with aq classifier is it
university or company or is it society
yeah so
there is one
nice answer that i want to read is that
all of us should be responsible
so in practice there is very little
awareness about
understanding what problems are ethical
or not and there is no clear policies
here right this is a complicated issue
and it's not clear who is responsible
this is why assuming that
and of whoever is aware of such dangers
should be responsible
so i don't know what is the right answer
to this question
so now what is the difference between
the chicken classifier and the q
classifier
right so one of your answers is that
one is affect people and one does not
right and while chicken classifier
actually affects chicken lives and iq
classifier will not kill anyone it can
harm but will not kill
we do feel that iq classifier currently
is
can have potentially worse impacts
so ai systems are pervasive in our world
and the
question about ethics are specifically
raised commonly about people-centered ai
systems and these systems are really
pervasive so they interact with people
like conversational agents
they reason about people
such as profiling
applications or recommendation systems
they affect people in other lives like
parole decision applications that i
mentioned
face recognition voice recognition
all of these actually have this
component of prediction predictive
technology and the human human-centered
technology and this is why ethics is
critical here
so i want to move to a next study
the next study is
a study of
detecting
so we again build a classifier and we
want to identify uh
the ability to accurately identify one
sexual
orientation from mere observation
so this study is
called ai gaydar
so and there are as i mentioned many
similar studies studies that predict
potential for terrorist attacks
studies that predict uh predictive
policing
and also if you heard about cambridge
analytica all of them incorporate very
similar technology
so let's talk about the style about aig
dar study and the goal is to understand
again
what kind of questions we could ask
about this study
and what kind of
pitfalls
we could prevent if we would ask these
questions
so to summarize this study
uh the recent question is
uh i we need to identify the sexual
orientation from people's images
and
the data collection process is that we
can download photos from a popular
american dating website
and
there are 35 000 pictures
all white
equally represent equal representation
for gay and straight for male and female
everybody is represented uh evenly
the method that was used
is a deep learning model to extract
facial features and grooming features
and then a logistic regression
classifier applied
to classify the final label geostrate
and the accuracy of this classifier is
81 for men and 74 for women so this is a
summary of the study
and the
i see rightfully asked questions why
would we ever need such a nice system
this is a good question but
i don't want to publicize this study or
disparage specific researcher but this
is a good study to present as an example
of what could go wrong at all levels of
the study
so this is why i'm discussing it now so
what went wrong here
so let's start with an ethics of the
research question
so
is it
ethical at all to predict sexual
orientation from facial from any kind of
features
and i
i see a lot of comments and thank you
for the comments
um
so
first of all this is not a new research
question
uh
from 19th century there were multiple
studies to correlate sexual identity
with some external features
people were and then with genetics
people were looking for gay genes gay
brains gay ring fingers and so on
so maybe moving from 19th century
to 21 century
we can again ask who can be you who can
benefit from such a classifier and who
can
be harmed by such a classifier so what
do you think who could benefit from such
a classifier
so
autocratic governments
right
but also maybe dating ups advertisers
conservative religious groups
and so on so we could think who could
who would want to use such a classifier
then
maybe who can be harmed by such a
classifier
now again assuming we we are not
thinking if it's possible at all be with
such a classifier and as you can guess
we will see
that it's not possible
but
what would stop you from building such a
classifier what do you think could could
be harmful in this classifier
so
yeah thank you for your answers
i will summarize them so
many people can be harmed by such
classifier and i summarize basically
many of your answers here in this slide
so
this potentially can be a dangerous
technology so in many countries being
gay person is prosecutable by law
and it can lead even to this penalty it
might affect people's employment
relationships health opportunities right
importantly
this is not only about sexual
orientation
so
there are many attributes
including sexual identity
that are private
for people right these are protected
attributes and
they are they can be non-binary they can
be intimate and not visible publicly and
most importantly is that
these attributes are specifically those
attributes against which people are
discriminated against
and this is why it is basically
dangerous to build such technology
so in the
paper in the published paper
the argument for building this for
basically presenting this study was that
this study is an alert how easy it is to
build such a classifier
uh
and the basically an alert for um
to expose the thread to the privacy and
safety of people
and then i would be interested to hear
if you have counter arguments this
argument
okay so basically
there can be many counter arguments one
of them is that
this is a classifier this technology so
like a knife is a technology
and with a knife you can kill people and
you can
cook food right and you don't you're not
necessarily need to kill people with a
knife to expose the dangers and harms of
this technology right
and another issue
is that
this is actually
not possible to build such a classifier
with the data that researchers had and
this is what we will see
when we will discuss
kind of additional details about the
data
and another comment is as i said this is
only one instance of such a technology
that here is another instance which is
it's a successful startup called
phaseception
which uh
has drawn a lot of funding and its goal
is to identify terrorists based on
facial features
and unlike in the previous study the
startup doesn't show how they what
technology they develop
but
you can guess that it can have
similar dangers so in general
uh building predictive technology is
very
pervasive it's ubiquitous but it is
always in it and sometimes it's not as
kind of
[Music]
clear-cut unethical for
example many people in nlp published
papers on predicting gender from
comments
and it is not clear basically when
the technology is clearly harmful and
unethical and where it can be actually
used or in good ways for example we all
want
our search to work right and to work
well and to be personalized
the algorithm actually needs to know
something about us so again this is not
an easy question but in the case of the
dark classifier
maybe the it's already on the extreme
okay let's move to the data
[Music]
again to discuss basically
what questions could we ask about the
data so here is how the data was
collected so photos were downloaded from
a popular american dating website they
were public
and
there were
a few few
thousand of images all white and the
balanced data set
and my first question is
uh what can you say about
the data so is it okay to use this data
if there is no robots.txt the photos are
public what can be counter arguments to
using people's photos from a dating
website
there is a there is a hint
on the on the slide
lack of consent
people did not intend to for their
photos to be used to build the
classifier
private information right so thank you
for your answers
so the points that i wanted to emphasize
here is that
it was legal to collect this data but
again it's not clear whether it was
ethical to collect this data because as
you said people did not provide maybe
did not provide 35 000 people did not
provide consent for using specifically
this data
and there are more important global
issue here is that there is a difference
between data that is public
and data which is publicized
so public it's fine because these people
want to be found by the social
circle that they are targeting when they
publish their photo on the dating
website
but this does not mean necessarily that
they want to be found by a broader
social circle by their families by their
colleagues and so on so there is a big
difference between the data that is
public and the
data which is publicized
so overall even if they did not violate
state
terms of service
i don't know about it i didn't read
in depth actually
but uh they did violate the social
contract because this was not the intent
of the user
for their data to be used in this way
next question
uh about data so
what do you think about this data set 35
000 of pictures
all white
balanced in terms of sexual orientation
and balanced in terms of gender
it's white
okay so
does not represent the population
so right so basically you can guess that
this data set has many many biases
incorporated
it contains only white people only
people who have who self-disclose their
sexual identity
it
it is represents very certain social
groups people who put their photos on
the dating website of specific age of
specific ethnicity
and basically these are photos that were
carefully selected to be attractive
so
to to their target audience
so this data set contains many types of
biases
and also as
one of you mentioned and as is written
on this slide that this data set
is balanced which does not represent the
whole the true distribution in the
population so what does it mean
this means that
this model
is built on a very biased data set
and you as a
student at stanford
you understand that
it cannot be used for example on a
non-white population
it cannot be used on photos of people
not from their
dating website we don't actually know
how this what this classifier learned
maybe this the most important features
where the watermark of this specific
website i don't know or some other
confounds spurious confounds but the
point is that once the classifier is out
those who want to use it maliciously
they don't know that this technology is
actually not applicable for any other
data set except for this specific data
set
so this technology is biased and it also
shows that it's basically
not a credible
result
okay
so let's move on
and
final question is that basically this is
a deep learning model it's a black box
model and then there is a question of
how to
analyze errors in the
learning model specifically when we work
on such a critical such as sensitive
topics like predictive technology not
necessarily predicting sexual
orientation but for example predicting
gender which is again used in many
companies
so
it is very difficult to understand
whether it is okay to use this
technology but the point is that we need
to be able to analyze it and
evaluate it properly
and the the last point
is about the accuracy again and i'm
going back to the
points that i mentioned also in the iq
classifier so the accuracy of this
classifier is 80 1 for men and 74
for women
is it a good accuracy or is it a bad
accuracy
so the numbers are okay for some tasks
but not for others but importantly for
this specific for this type of problem
it's important understand that the cost
of misclassification
is not equal to the cost of correct
prediction
and here is kind of visual examples
so
if my algorithm misclassifies my dog as
a cookie
um
is the cost misclassification of this
misclassification is high or low
so i guess it's just funny right it's a
it's funny there is nothing offensive
here
and then the next question if my
algorithm misclassifies
me with my dog
is the cost of misclassification high or
low
it can be funny but maybe not for
everyone we already don't know
and then the photo that i don't put here
but the one that is maybe many of you
have heard is the gorilla incident that
happened in google in 2016.
so in this case
there was a misclassification of an
african-american woman with a guerrilla
and to understand how expensive is the
cost of this clinic classification
we need to understand the whole history
of dehumanization
of
black people in the earth and so on
so
we we can see the difference for the
same algorithm and same types of errors
there are different types of errors that
are more expensive than others
so this is why
it is important to assess ai systems
adversarially and now i just want to
reiterate the types of questions that i
asked because these are the kinds of
questions that you might want to ask
yourself
next time when you need to build another
predictive technology
and the first is to understand the
ethics of the research version and
sometimes it's not very easy to
understand
but
just ask yourself these more specific
questions
if i build this technology who could
benefit from such a technology
and who can be harmed by it so try to
see the corner cases
and also
what about the data could sharing this
data have major effect on people's lives
like in the case of aigdar classifier
the next question that you can ask is
about privacy what we discuss
who owns the data and is this data not
only public or legal to use but also is
it are we violating the social
basically circles to which the data is
publicized
are we violating a social contract in
the way that the
public data is expected to be used and
user consent is not always
possible to obtain
but we need to understand implicit
assumptions of people who put their data
online
now the next question is what what are
possible biases in data what are
artifacts and data
what are uh distributions for specific
populations and sub-populations how
representative or what kind of
misrepresentations are in my data
and next is
what is basically potential bias in
these models though i when i build this
model do i control for confined
variables
and do i optimize for the right
objective like in the case of the iq
classifier
and also if i have biases does my system
amplify biases
and finally it is not enough to measure
accuracy
because
the
kind of semantics of false positives and
false negatives can be different
sometimes the cost of misclassification
is much higher than the cost of correct
prediction so
also need to understand how to evaluate
the models properly
and why is it especially relevant now is
because
as you all know
there is an exponential growth of user
generated data and it's really easy to
build the tools each of us can build the
iq classifier or gadar
but the question is
what kind of technology we will produce
so this finishes
in this i finished the first part of
discussion and i put in this slide some
recommended papers and talks
specifically on the kind of introductory
topics on the impact of nlp and i think
these are
there are hundreds or thousands of
similar talks but i like these are my
favorites so if you want to read more
please take a look
should i stop for questions or should we
move to the next uh
the part
right at the moment there aren't any
outstanding questions so maybe it's okay
to move on unless anyone's desperately
typing
okay
and
the chat window is really nice there are
so many responses thank you all and i
hope to get
later this um
i think we can save it yeah thank you
okay we can move on to the second part
about algorithmic bias
so
what are the topics in the intersection
of ethics in
nlp so the first one is algorithmic bias
and this is about bias and data and nlp
models and this is something that i will
talk more in the second part but
important to understand that the field
is much broader
so the next topic is incivility so
ability to develop nlp tools
to identify to actually data analytics
to understand the hate speech toxicity
incivility online and this is a very
complicated field because it's not only
about building the right classifiers
there are many many questions such as if
i post hateful comment
who does this comment belong to does it
belong to a company
does it belong to me
should it be removed or not because it
is not clear where is the boundary
between the free speech
and the
moderated speech
how to minimize the harms but defend the
democracy these questions are very
subjective and they are not regulated
so this is a big difficult uh field
the next field is about privacy
so again who does this data belong to
and how to protect privacy this uh
field of privacy is actually very very
underexplored in nlp among other fields
i think there is some research on
incivility or logarithmic bias on other
fields
but very little research on
privacy
misinformation so
information manipulation opinion
manipulation fake news so there is a
whole range of ways the data can be
manipulated from generated texts and the
disinformation
to
just
advertisement and the more subtle or
propaganda and subtle opinion
manipulation
and the
there are many many interesting research
projects that can be done
really with the focus on the language of
manipulation which i think is just an
interesting topic to explore
and finally the technological divide so
when we build our tools even if it's a
part of speech dagger
who what are populations for which which
are served by these tools so there is a
certain divide the technologies are
built unequally there is no one language
no
two languages there are six thousand
languages in the world and there are
many populations and there are certain
areas of nlp which are completely
underexplored for example language
varieties we think we can solve the
problem for english the problem of
dependency parsing but we don't account
for different varieties of english what
about nigerian english what about
african-american english
what about indian english so
there are
the
there is a technological divide that is
currently present as and as you see in
the bottom this is uh this picture shows
that
the field is highly interdisciplinary so
ai researchers can only cannot actually
solve the problem of
misinformation alone to be able to
address the problem of misinformation or
hate speech we need to have not only
engineers
but also ethicists and social scientists
and the activists
and the
politicians who actually
are responsible for policies
and linguists because many of these
phenomena are interesting
phenomena which are not in words but
more in pragmatics
so this is a very interesting field
scientifically but also very challenging
to work on
and there are some recommended resources
and in particular the one that might be
interesting to you all is uh
cs384 is a seminar by don jorovsky that
has an amazing also list so if you want
to take a look on
specific subfields
so this is a general overview and now i
want to talk about
one of these some fields and give some
of explanation why do we have
algorithmic bias in our models
so
um
let's start
again with interaction
i know you have the slides but don't
look forward
i want to ask you questions and please
type
which word is more likely to be used by
a female giggle or love
just type quickly don't think too much
so please look at the chat and see the
majority response
it is
absolutely giggle
you're right
next question which word is more likely
to be used by a female brutal affairs
oh lovely
it's like
uh
thank you
next question
which word is more likely to be used by
an older person impressive or amazing
so actually from what i see it's 100
impressive
very impressive thank you for answers
which word is more likely to be used by
a person of a higher occupational class
suggestions or proposals
do you see how correctly you answer my
questions
so next question why do we intuitively
recognize the default social why do we
all know the right answer
right
our brains are biased so this is about
implicit biases in our brains
and this is a very good example and you
can also see how language perpetuates
and propagates biases right it's all in
the language if you could know from one
word who is the person who said it you
can imagine what kind of biases we can
extract from a longer text
so to understand what's happening with
biases we need to understand how
cognition works
so we have
this is was introduced by caliman and
versky so conceptually our brain is
divided into system one is system too so
system one is our autopilot it is used
to make decisions without thinking it is
very fast parallel effortless and so on
system two is our logical part it knows
how to analyze and make decisions that
are unusual for us so it is not
automatic and it is slow serial
controlled
uh it requires a lot of mental energy
so our brain constantly receives signals
all kinds of
from through all the sensors through
eyes airs there is a lot of incoming
data there is a lot of pixels here
around me
but the actual part of system two
is only able to produce a very small
portion of the signals that we received
so system one is automatic system two is
effortful
but in practice over 95 in practice over
95 percent
of the signals that we receive from the
world is relegated to system one
and the funny thing is as kahneman wrote
is that we identify ourselves with
system two we believe that we are
conscious and the reasonable beings but
in practice most of our decisions are
made by system one
so
uh
so since we are using auto pilot most of
our time our our kind of brain uh get
every all the information that we
perceive gets categorized clusters
and
like labeled automatically and this is
how cognitive stereotypes are created
so and there are multiple multiple
cognitive stereotypes that are aimed to
fill the gaps if we don't have enough
meaning
or reduce information generalize if we
have too much information
or to
complete the facts if we are missing
facts and so on and this leads to all
kinds of cognitive biases so examples of
biases would be
in-group favoritism so we
grow up
seeing the majority of specific people
and we tend to like those people more
than the minorities
uh hollow effect that we know very
little about the person or a specific
social group but we tend to generalize
based on one trait we could generalize
about the whole group and to other
traits
and so on there are many biases
and
[Music]
thanks to these stereotypes if i if i
ask you the questions the words or if i
show you these pictures you immediately
know this is a calming cute tasty and if
i show these pictures you will know that
maybe it's dangerous unpleasant and
automatically when we see a snake we
will not will automatically step down
right
step back and we only need to um
make system to invo evoke system two for
example if we decide to touch it but
most of our decisions are automatic and
this is the same exactly mechanism that
creates social stereotypes in our brains
so
we exactly in the same mechanism
internalize these associations
and the
make generalizations about specific
groups
so and this is why when when i ask you
which word is more likely to use by an
older person 100 of you typed that
the word impressive would be used
and importantly
these implicit biases are very pervasive
and they operate unconsciously and one
important property is that they are
transitive so basically where people we
are seeing that a black person is
playing basketball and in the movie we
see that a black person uses drugs and
we immediately connected and reinforce
the for example the associations with
the specific groups
and the
social stereotypes are not necessarily
all negative
i can name some uh on the surface
positive stereotypes for example asians
are good in math
importantly they all have negative
effect even seemingly positive
stereotypes because they pigeonhole
individuals and put expectations of them
or they can just be harmful
and then how do these biases manifest
they manifest in language and for
example they manifest in subtle
microaggressions
uh
and importantly
microaggressions
not correlate necessarily with sentiment
so
sentiment analysis tools would not
detect them
on the surface level
microaggressions can be negative neutral
or positive like in these examples
but they actually bring prolonged harms
even if they're meant as a
complement
and there was a lot of research in
social sciences that showed that they
can
even bring more harms that overt hate
speech because they implicit they kind
of bring a significant emotional harm
and reinforce problematic stereotypes
so if i will collect these conversations
from twitter do i look okay you're so
pretty is this a positive or negative
it's probably positive interaction
and then the next interaction
check out my new physics paper is it
positive or negative interaction
uh why physics are you so you're so
pretty so we don't know we don't have
the right context
and then for this question do i look
okay
and the all kinds of responses for
example you are so pretty for your age
in this case these are negative these
are microaggressions they make us cringe
right
and then the problem is that all of
these human generated data which is
necessarily kind of incorporates a lot
of microaggressions and just stereotypes
that we all have we are not aware of
them
it is it is fed to our systems
so there is a lot of bias in
language like stereotypes or historical
biases that are perpetuated for example
there are more photos of
men doctors than female doctors on the
web
or human reporting biases
and later there are biases also in our
data sets so for example what kind of
data we sample for annotation from which
kind of populations from which language
varieties from which locations and then
who are we choosing as annotators so
there is a bias in who are annotators
that will annotate our data
and then there is bias or cognitive
biases of annotators themselves how they
treat what is the microaggression and
what is not or in other questions
and
all these types of biases later
propagate into our computational systems
and this is how we get from cognitive
bias social cognitive biases to
algorithmic biases because if you
remember system one is system two
currently the way we develop systems
ai is only system one
and why is that because
currently the way we kind of develop our
tools the
dominant paradigm is a data centric
approach so we need a lot of data to
train good models
and we do know well how to leverage a
lot of data but again language is about
people it is produced by people
and but our existing systems they
they do not leverage social cultural
context
we don't know how to incorporate
uh and of
we don't do it usually we don't
incorporate which social biases are
positive and which inductive biases are
good and which inductive biases are bad
to have
so overall
our models are really powerful and they
are powerful at making generalizations
but we don't know how to control for the
right inductive biases which biases each
inductive biases are good and which
inductive biases are not
and then
going to the next point is that these
models are opaque right we don't also
know how to interpret well deep learning
networks which means
it's not easy to analyze them and spot
their problems
so
and as you can guess this is not only
related to the field of ethical nlp
these are just interesting research
questions how to incorporate social and
cultural knowledge into deep learning
models or how to
develop interpret interpretation
approaches
so
what is missing
today what is missing for example is
that existing uh classifiers for
toxicity
detection if we want to build data
analytics to to clean up our data before
it propagates to the models
we know only how to detect overt toxic
language such as hate speech because we
are primarily sampling our data and
training our data based on
lexicons and there is almost no
focus on actual um
microaggressions and more subtle biases
which are often not in words
but in pragmatics of the conversation
and understanding who are the people
involved in the conversation
so
today's tools they could be applied to
this kind of microaggressions
or hate speech detection or sentiment
analysis but they will necessarily fail
the next point is that
again our models do not incorporate
social cultural knowledge and the
basically the same comment can be toxic
or non-toxic depending on who are the
people involved in the conversation
but our models are data centric and not
people-centric
and
the more general problem is that the
deep learning models
are really good at picking spurious
correlations
and the uh this is why for example in
this paper
the three comments which chain which
the only difference in these
three sentences is a name and probably
the association of this name
with
race or ethnicity
so our models do beat up on spurious
confounds so we think we predict
sentiment but we also predict all kinds
of labels that correlate with sentiment
but not necessarily are true predictors
of sentiment for example gender or race
and this is something very pervasive
so and finally the models are not
explainable
so we kind of have these deficiencies
just in core approaches to deep learning
and we have all these data and with this
data we train conversational agents
personal assistants all kinds of systems
and
why do we care now because it can bring
harms
so what kind of unintended harms it can
bring
um
here is an example of an image search if
you search for three black teenagers and
this is i searched for it when i
prepared this talk for the first time so
it was fixed i guess but this is how it
was in june 2017
and then
when you search for a doctor
you get primarily
male doctors right and primarily white
and if you search for a nurse
this is a stereotypical image of a nurse
and if you search for a homemaker
this is this this is a just top search
results for this query words and if you
search for ceo
it's a
very specific stereotypical image of ceo
and if you search for a professor this
one is my my personal favorite so you
can see all the
male images and there is
only one woman but if you look at her
background you can see these are simple
math facts so it's just an error in
search she is not a professor
and this is a result of for example
speech
face recognition so
these are two examples
uh
one camera does not recognize asian
faces and things they're blinked on the
right the camera this is a video of a
face tracking camera that is able to
track white faces but immediately shuts
down when black face comes so it is not
able to track black faces
so these are all consequences
of biased data that propagates into
models that do not incorporate
intentionally
basically safeguards against very
specific biases
now what's going on with natural
language processing so this is a slide
from the very beginning and i just list
all possible applications that i could
think about
as you can guess since 2016 there are
many many papers that just i don't think
there is any application or core
technologies of nlp left which did not
expose biases in nlp technologies
so here is an example of bias in machine
translation so this is visual this is
why i'm showing it so
there are languages that
mark third person third person pronouns
with gender and other languages that do
not mark third person pronounced gender
so if you translate with from a language
such as
hungarian or from estonian that
don't
mark third person pronoun this gender
into english which does mark third
person pronoun with the gender you might
see similar results you will not see
them now this is uh
[Music]
what was exposed maybe a year or two ago
so
basically from translation from they are
the nurse this would be she's a nurse
but they are the scientists the
translations would be he's a scientist
and same for engineer baker teacher so
all the stereotypes just historical
stereotypes that you could think about
so what are
possibilities to fix it
one way to fix it
is
actually simple you could treat the
target gender just as a target language
is multilingual nmt so i i don't know
but i suspect you did look at this paper
on a multilingual neural machine
translation
and
basically you can add another token for
example and you can controllably
generate into
female or male translation so the fix is
not difficult but you need to be aware
of potential dangers to be
able to fix model
and importantly this is not about only
about fixing the model itself but also
about fixing the user interface right so
the way google fixed this interface is
they provided different translation so
basically all possible translations for
different genders
so in the similar kind of harms were
shown especially in dialogue systems so
occasionally such models make big
headings and news like
microsoft's
chat bot that became
very racist and sexist overnight
and the gpt3 based models that was
offering a suicide advice and about two
weeks ago there was a korean chatbot
that became extremely homophobic very
quickly quickly and had to be removed so
these titles come up again this
headlines coming again and again and
again
and
i guess the point here is that what the
way we do nlp today
i call it a reactive approach
so we have we expose a specific problem
by a problem in search a problem in chat
bots
racist check bots or a problem in
machine translation and then it gives it
creates bad publicity and then we start
devising the models
but it's not necessarily that we need to
develop the tools in this way right so
i hope that kind of in the future we
make a paradigm shift towards the more
proactive approach
and the
specific
what would proactive approach
require is for example um
building new data analytics
so basically
rather than exposing biases going
further up the pipeline and starting
actually with the data and building
automatic moderators and data analytics
that can identify problematic text
problematic images beyond the working
hate speech and then incorporating the
right inductive biases into the models
and understanding what
kind of understanding moving from
the data-centered approaches to
people-centered approaches incorporating
social cultural and pragmatic knowledge
and in modeling there are interesting
research questions on how to
demote spurious confounds but predict
only the target label not necessarily
picking up on spurious correlations
and finally on building more
interpretable models and importantly
that these are not orthogonal research
directions
so for example to build good data
analytics
you necessarily
need to
maybe have an interpretable model and
also be able to incorporate the
right social cultural knowledge
because again the microaggressions the
text is not necessarily in words
so what i was going to do
if i had time is i would i was going to
show two case studies from research
studies from my group that specifically
focus on these data analytics
identifying unsupervised bias or
an interpretable model for making uh
hate speech classifiers more robust but
i will skip it
because we are out of time good show
what you've still got a few minutes you
can show one quickly for five minutes
so
basically we are we are trying to build
this like green boxes is what we have
today
hate speech or sentiment analysis
but we are trying to build a new kind of
class of models specifically for social
bias analysis
and in these
models we would want to detect
who are the people involved so who the
common for example is directed to if
it's a conversational domain and also to
understand what kinds of
microaggressions these are
and also to maybe generate explanations
or interpretations through
building more interpretable models
and the
these are
the two
papers that i was going to talk about
one is an unsupervised approach to
detection gender bias
and one is on if we have just few
examples of microaggressions and the
classifier of hate speech
these examples of microaggressions are
adversarial examples to the classifier
the classifier is not able to deal with
them but what we can do we can focus on
interpretability of the classifier and
specifically
making the classifier understanding for
each probing example
which examples in the training data
influenced the classifier's decision so
changing the approach to
interpretability from interpreting
specific salient words in the input of
the classifier
into looking at the training data
sorting the training data and
identifying
which examples were most influential
for classifier predictions so using
inference functions for example and
this is a
paper that
percy
published in 2017
and
through this classifier we are able to
surface microaggressions
despite that the questifier makes the
wrong prediction so this is just a high
level
very high level summary without talking
about the actual studies
so i will skip
let me just skip
the
actual papers and the slides are there
i'm happy to discuss later just don't
want to go over
time so
to summarize
the field of computational ethics is
super interesting and there are
interesting problems that are
technically interesting they're
challenging so
you don't need to have a separate kind
of important problems and the
technically interesting problems we can
work on important problems which are
also technically interesting and focus
on
important things like
building better deep learning models
and these are interesting subfields and
if some of you are interested in
specific projects so it's just in our
course we
we just put together
a presentation that
um
just
summarizes all kinds of possible
projects that you could do
well thank you very much
okay i wish i could see the audience
this is so um
thank you julia for that great talk um
yeah so um if people
would like to ask some questions to
yulia um if you raise your hand
we can promote you to be panelists and i
think then we can even have you turn on
your cameras if you if you want to
feel a real human being um
um
but you know if we're waiting to see if
there are people who would like to do
that i mean there is one question that's
um outstanding at the moment which is um
do these bots become racist sexist so
quickly after exposure to the public due
to the public intentionally trying to
bias them or is it that common talk
among the public is racist sexist enough
to bias any moral upon exposure
so i think this is both but in the case
for example of tai both the way it was
built is it's a continual learning
system so it collects uh
inputs from people and then uses them as
a
training examples
uh to generate forward answers and the
people as usually people pick up on such
things very quickly and then they
intentionally became racist and the
sexist again against the bot and they
both very quickly learn to just mimic
the people's behavior so it was some
malicious attempt to
kind of turn this boat into racist and
sexist
but this is how the model was designed
to collect
inputs from people
but
not monitor the kind of sentences that
are used or not used in the training
data so this is again going back to the
discussion of that we actually don't
have good analytics many of these
analytics are
these are just
at least so whitelist they're very very
primitive it's not
very easy to incorporate such
constraints into
generation automatic filtering of data
there is another question
can i ask my question yes yes so i guess
you guys most questions
i
um
are there actually public benchmark
datasets you can or any sort of
well-defined metric that you can sort of
uh
objectively measure your model's
improvements
are you talking about specifically our
papers that i skipped
just in general are there
i mean i know it's a very new field and
maybe it's harder to define really
objective
measure of bias
so how how do you measure progress in
general well you can also just mention
this this is a good question it's very
difficult it's like there are there is
growing body of data sets
for example in udab asian choice group
created the social bias in
inference corpus
i don't remember what ice
sbic
overall
the problem of evaluation is actually
very difficult
and there are some problems in which
there are
existing evaluation data sets if you
think about hate speech for example
there are all kinds of
data sets there are many data sets for
training and evaluating and
performance of hate speech classifiers
but when we think about biases
there are much less
and the the big problem here it's not
easy to collect such a data set so if
you think
let me actually
show why why it is difficult to collect
a data set of say of microaggressions
so a naive solution would be to
uh
so if you think about the standard way
of the data collection so we would
sample some data from the internet and
we give it to mechanical torque and
annotators
and then they would analyze is it bias
or not and we built the supervised
specifier so this is what we cannot do
in the case of most subtle biases
first because we don't have a strong
lexical sieve to sample the right data
because again these biases are not in
words what like you just sample from the
whole reddit corpus it's not clear how
to annotate to make it feasible not too
expensive but more importantly that
every annotator will incorporate their
own biases so you actually need very
well trained annotators and multiple
annotations per sample
so the question of how to create such a
data set is very very difficult
in our study we collected the
so there is a core
website called microaggressions.com
that has self-reported microaggressions
when people actually
recall experiences of
[Music]
microaggressions against them and they
quote them
and this is what we use to evaluate
our data but the data collection is as a
big problem currently as
just modeling
do you want to ask a question
no yeah
i don't have any other questions for us
oh sorry
okay so i should go on um
uh can you hear me yes
yeah uh thanks for the yeah great
lecture it's a very appropriate topic
for the sketch launcher
um
so i took the course cs182 uh which
introduced many
notions of fairness through case studies
and
assignments
uh i've been thinking a lot about some
of these notions and of course there was
like mention for
research done by kleinberg who showed uh
three different notions of fairness can
be simultaneously satisfied the
calibration which is like
the probability of outcome given risk
scores
the false positive rate the false
negative rate cannot all be
like completely independent across
protective traits
so if like past a certain point you know
these metrics just become direct
trade-offs
uh is it the case that fairness becomes
subjective after that
and i guess like more generally
you know in
ethics research has there have been
frameworks of
creating sort of upper bounds or
constraints among these different
metrics
uh so we sort of measure how close we
get to the ideal
[Music]
this is a very difficult question so
right the fairness research there are
actually proofs that you cannot satisfy
both
the measures of
the performance and inclusivity
and the
this is why they are measured separately
false positives false negatives and uh
the question is whether it
because because of this issue whether it
becomes subjective
um
it's even bigger i guess the question
here is even bigger because
um
the question of inclusivity
so
it competes with the question of
monetization like if you think who are
the main owners of data and how they
train algorithms
the goal is to basically have better
monetization like who will see this
advertisement
but
there is a competing objective of
inclusivity who like to will this
advertisement reach out to
all kinds of populations
and uh it's not only it's not subjective
there is a kind of there is a clear
incentive
for example in companies
to maximize monetization rather than
inclusivity right because it's also
internal
i
i don't have an easy answer to this i
agree it can be subjective or can be
worse than subjective because like these
objectives are
compete
so would you say it's sort of
more
uh the field of you know ethics research
overall is more interdisciplinary and
you know a lot of these answers to
these questions are more context
dependent it's very context dependent
right it is very context dependent as i
mentioned for example
the the same application in in different
uh contexts can be
used for good and for bed right and the
different thresholds on
performance can be applied for different
types of
for different settings
and also i really think like i'm not
qualified even to answer this question
right we should ask maybe a philosopher
or
experts in policy right because
eventually i'm um
i know how to build the
the tools
and i'm trying to like i'm trying to
make technologies
kind of more ethical but the question of
how they are deployed and what are
specific decisions it's um
it's very difficult to control for and
to kind of give definite answers about
this
well here's another gold question for
you from
and you can't use that cop-out answer
um so
i said earlier you showed the example of
ai gada with the question of why would
we want to study this the author is
justified by claiming that given the
widespread use of facial recognition our
findings have critical
implications for the protection of civil
liberties given that some unscrupulous
governments may indeed implement such
technology to oppress minorities based
on such things as orientation do social
scientists have an obligation to get
ahead of this threat by understanding
the properties of such models how do we
weigh the ethical trade-offs
oh gosh
now i need to respond from the
point of view of all social scientists
i
i don't want to answer philosophical
questions but i i kind of
i have the answer about um
maybe a simple answer to
why i don't agree with
the claim of researchers that we need to
expose this technology to publish
actually this paper to expose the
dangers of this technology
uh
one of them like the knife analogies
that i gave is one of the answers so if
you think about
similar field like not a similar field
but a similar type of
interaction
uh in
security right in cyber security so
it's very common to kind of break
the algorithm to show its
vulnerabilities and then to iteratively
fix it so this is like the approach that
researchers took let's uh show the
vulnerabilities like that we are able to
build this technology
to expose its threats
but unlike with the
security field
here the kind of exposure of this
technology publication of this
technology can have real
implications of
human life so again the cost of
misclassification
and the
if we think about
other problems
like similar problems like the problems
of like i can give many other similar
problems in which
we can expose this technology which will
harm people like let's uh
let's create
deep fakes video a port video with
professors
we can do it right to expose the danger
of technology of dick fakes
but what kind of harm it will bring to
specific people who were involved in
this kind of exposure of the harm of
this technology
so i have the answer of why kind of it
was wrong to publish this study in the
first place
and why it's not productive it's not
helpful but it's very difficult to
answer the question what
should social scientists do i don't know
okay
well i could like ask the question next
oh it just disappeared right oh wait i
think can you hear me now yeah
okay
um thank you so much for the talk that's
really interesting and
as we've just seen really challenging
stuff um i guess my question is a little
bit more practical so maybe that's a
reprieve for you but
um
i like unfortunately it seems like in a
lot of
um nlp and ai more broadly some of this
ethics and bias stuff is like kind of an
afterthought um a lot of projects don't
really necessarily take it into the into
account from the outset and it's more
sort of incidental
um so my question is like you know as
we're working on
um nlp projects maybe even our final
course project
like what are some kind of concrete
steps that we can take or like a
systematic approach that we can use to
sort of incorporating some of this
ethics
um knowledge in things that might not
explicitly seem like they have a lot to
do with ethics
so
it depends on the project right it's
like i cannot answer generally if
the first part of the lecture
was exactly about this
if i if i build my project what kind of
questions i can ask to know if there are
some pitfalls
if
it's a like
if it's a different project i think
overall
these are
important questions which are general
for deep learning models
which could be later used to create a
better technology so
how to incorporate
understanding who are the people
who produce the language or who are the
users of incorporating the right
inductive biases or a technology for
demoting confounds it doesn't have to be
relate like specifically on ethics
related problems
or interpretability of deep learning it
doesn't have to be
ethics enough project
but the kind of technology if you can
develop such a technology eventually it
can be useful for building such better
like proactive proactively models that
proactively prevent
unintended harms
so i guess
the the strategy would be sort of to
just lay out these
these general topics
pose these questions to yourself maybe
write them down or just think about them
and then proceed as such
yeah so i this is how i think about it i
think about
potential like if this technology would
be deployed
what could be corner cases what is
potential for dual use
uh if it works how kind of
how can it be misused
and
also when it doesn't work what kind of
errors can be harmful so this is uh
if you go back to in the slides to the
beginning of the lecture these questions
they could be
applied to many kinds of technology and
it they they give a more clear kind of
guidelines to what things how like bad
outcomes could be prevented
i'm sure maybe i'm missing something
totally right it's
all of this content much of this content
is just i came up about on with it by
reading a lot of
different papers but there is no clear
guidelines it's such a new field
so maybe there are things that i'm also
missing
here's another question from
um are models wrong for being biased in
the end they just learn what they're
designed to learn and isn't our
intervention to correct this behavior
actually our cause of bias
this is a good question so
it is kind of it it is a question that i
also have been thinking about like
uh are models wrong for for example
reflecting accurately the real world
right do we need to devise actively
models to
to make them fair when the world is not
fair when our data is not fair
so first of all
the way we train models today they don't
only
perpetuate biases they amplify biases
so this is
an natural behavior of a machine
learning model
that
basically when you have
you have an input example for which the
confidence is lower it will default to a
majority class
this is why
if your data contains biases these
biases will be amplified in a more in a
machine learning model trained on this
data
and this is clearly wrong
uh whether it is wrong to
kind of
to build models that do not reflect the
actual true distribution in the data
it's much more difficult questions but
there are clear
there are clear kind of cases in which
i would say it is wrong to build a model
that
that in the search for ceo shows only
male ceos why
while kind of
because it amplifies biases but
yeah this is already a subjective kind
of answer it's just my personal opinion
it has
not much to do with the research that we
are doing right or
well
would you like to ask your
question oh yeah one sec clipped me
okay i was trying to start my video but
it's saying i can't so i guess i'm just
gonna ask um by the way i don't see
people anyway
well you look like a started video but
yeah anyway let's just go
yeah yeah i'll just ask oh yeah so thank
you so much for your talk um i have a
question microaggressions um so who is
to decide what it is what is considered
a microaggression is it the people whom
microaggressions are potentially
targeted against is it philosophers or
social scientists or just you know
people in education and in case opinions
differ you know do we just listen to the
majority um it all seems crucially
important to me but very very difficult
to standardize and kind of reach a
consensus especially because different
cultures perceive things differently
thank you very much for these questions
these are amazing questions
these are difficult questions
this is why we did not create our own
corpus of microaggressions right because
it's culturally dependent it's very very
personal subjective this is why we pers
we focused on the corpus of
perceived microaggressions people that
actually
uh
felt
that
the
interactions were negative
because they knew that
these were microaggressions
it's um
who is to decide whether something is
microaggression
um
yeah
i don't know
this is very difficult
what i what i can think about like
practical solutions about it
um i would say
have a very well-trained annotators who
understand what microaggression is so
kind of we explain what is
microaggression they they see many
examples
they understand
that for example
a sentence that targets a minority group
and other things
and then have many annotators per one
sentence so like in
say
the study like this is about other
social concepts that are abstract for
example
in don jorovski's study on respect in
police interactions respect is also
a subjective thing right so what they
did they took every utterance and they
had multiple annotators multiple trained
annotators for each utterance and the
just increased kind of the number of
voters of whether
an utterance is respectful or not
so
like
practically i think this should be the
kind of procedure for creating corpus of
microaggressions
but uh more philosophical questions who
is who is to decide and
it's
it's a more difficult one yeah i got it
thank you so there are still more
questions but you're allowed to say that
you're worn out at any point julia and
if you're not the next question i feel
bad about not being able to answer big
questions about
society and
yeah i'm happy to answer
the next question
is um can you talk a bit more about the
unsupervised approach to identifying
implicit bias
i can it's
um
i just need to think how to talk about
it in a few words
so
intuitively
we cannot create a corpus of uh like
which has a utterance
um
which has an utterance and then a label
is it sentence biased or not
so we create a causal framework
in which
our target label is more objective who
is
who is the sentence directed to to a man
to a woman so our labels are gender
labels
uh and the
in a naive way if giving a sentence
towards a person without looking at the
actual person and the their comment just
by this comment told the person we can
predict if it's directed to a woman
uh
we can say that kind of there is some
bias and the more that there is some
bias in the sentence
but it's a naive approach because
there are other kind of
ways in which we can predict the target
gender
but
which will not be associated with bias
for example it's the context of the
current station the traits of the person
that we are writing to and so on so the
crux of our technology is that we
predict gender but demote all kinds of
confounds in the task of detecting bias
so we demote the signals of
the source sentence
we demote the latent traits of the
target person and so we make this task
very difficult to detect who is a target
what is the target gender and if after
all these demotions of the confounds
given us
utterance that is directed to a specific
person we can still classify this
utterance that is clearly directed to a
woman
we it is likely that this utterance
contains bias so what i was going to
talk is all kinds of demotion approaches
that we develop
but once we demo these approaches
and
the um we can still predict the
utterances who what is the gender of the
target receive we actually can surface
some biased sentences so these are the
main findings for example
if we look at the comments directed to
politicians
after all these demotions and we
see comments that um kind of clearly
predict the target gender
we can see that common store politicians
talk about their spouses about their
family love and also
like about
their competence maybe question their
competence
and if we look at comments towards
public figures like actresses
we can see a lot of words that are just
related to objectification sexualization
regardless of their source content so
they can talk about their movie but the
comments will always be about um
that
she is sexy and the this is what our
model is able to surface but it's again
it's just initial study
needs a lot of work
okay so around here also
asks if microaggressions are pulled from
a site where people can list what they
have experienced isn't that data very
vulnerable to social engineering
uh
yes
this data is vulnerable so in our case
we
anonymize this data we extract only
quotes from the data we removed actual
users who pop who published it remove
all the text around this quotes
and
this is a good question maybe we should
also not make this data public even yeah
hey um there are more questions thank
you
more questions um
so
by the way like if chris john and other
like i'm saying chris john because these
are the two faces faces that i see on my
screen
um please let me know when we need to
finish i'm happy to continue answering
i've often gone on for a few more
minutes so i can ask a couple more
questions um so here's one that's very
prominent in a.i right at the moment um
do you think it is fair for ai
scientists and tech and academia who are
definitely not representative of the
general population to decide what is
biased and what is not i.e the act of
devising itself might be biased
yeah this is one problem
also that
this is like more general problem that
researchers
even those who work on the biasing can
incorporate their own biases
um
we currently don't have any other
alternative right we don't have training
how to do it we don't have
i think it's a good thing to work on
these topics
to try to
promote these topics as much as possible
with an awareness that
we as researchers can incorporate our
own biases so this is what like we also
write in
ethical implications sections in the
paper that
we
try to identify bias we try to de-bias
but there are limitations to this study
because we could incorporate our own
biases into our analysis right this is
how we interpreted this results
maybe this is what we were looking for
and this is a confirmation bias
um
yeah
okay maybe maybe um should just have
one more
oh no a new question just turned up
maybe we'll have to be two questions
more
still coming in
um
now it's
i mean maybe i should do that one
immediately because it directly relates
to that answer um which was um from
how are the perspectives of community
stakeholders i people from minoritized
groups included when these systems are
being built
this is a wonderful question too yeah
currently not very good actually we have
currently have a paper also in
submission about analysis of what kind
of
how rays have been treated in nlp
systems starting from data sets to
models to
potential users
and one of the things that we found is
that even people who work on
identifying racism
they don't involve
actually
in group members
this is yeah you identified yet another
problem in the community that
perspectives
of community are not often incorporated
in our opposition paper we try to
advocate for its importance but
like all these questions are very good
but like there are maybe first somebody
like chris who has a lot of influence
could make changes
in the community it's very difficult to
make such changes
i guess i'm hopeful that there's
actually starting to be a bit of change
right now i mean you know
like one can be pessimistic given the
history
and one can be
pessimistic um given the current
statistics
but you know
i actually
believe that you know through recent
events of black lives matter and other
things that there's actually just
more
genuine
attempts to create change around
well certainly the stanford computer
science department but i think more
generally around the field of ai than
there's been at any time in the past 30
years when i've been watching it
right even when i did my postdoc at
stanford in 2016
um
we started working on the problem of
gender bias and it was total outlier
like i didn't know if
what i'm doing will be relevant to
anyone
and then now look we discussed this is a
kind of relevant question this is
already an amazing change in the
community and if there will be more
focus also on
right hiring which clearly now has more
awareness than ever
like right i'm also more optimistic now
than say
three years ago
okay or maybe this is wonderful
questions for which there are no good
answers yet yeah
um maybe you can do this as the last
question
um
unless you say something that really um
elicits a lot more
what do you think the social and ethics
space might look like say five to ten
years down the line do you think the
industry might come down to a unified
standard of ethics for ai systems given
that a lot of the challenges come from
the fact that social and ethics
discussions are often subjective
um
yeah i'm also optimistic about the field
of ethics in five years
these are difficult problems the the
field of ethics by the way itself is
2000 years old right
aristotle already asked these questions
now we're asking these questions about
ai but
giving the current awareness and the
and the
the bad publicities that company
currently companies are the main players
right it's more even than governments
and the
there is a big incentive with companies
to
fix things because of the bad publicity
and the
for example today i read an article
about
that google will stop
stop advertising the truck the profile
users
like these plugins
uh so overall i do see a very positive
trajectory it's very difficult to
predict what exactly will be like in
five years i don't think all the
problems will be resolved but overall
i'm optimistic also about
um
that
that new policies will be already that
not like not entirely in hands of
decisions of companies
and definitely about research because i
see how many students now are interested
in these topics which is totally amazing
okay oh and another comment that i want
to make is actually nlp is important in
all this
which was much less say the field of
fairness very much focused on the image
recognition but i think more and more we
will see more and more research on nlp
and language which is also exciting
okay uh well maybe um we should call it
quits at that point thank you so much
julia thank you very much